Fremont California an affluent suburb
located just outside of San Francisco
and home to Spin A Yarn a Landmark
restaurant that was taken over by a
Greek immigrant sake cabaneris at the
Chloe 1995 was kind of dying at the time
and gradually I brought it back to life
with spinner yarn booming it seemed as
if nothing could come between sake and
his dream
that is until a new addition came into
the restaurant I took the bartender job
it's been ERM because I was desperate
don't drop it whatever you did he asked
me if I had an experience and I said yes
but I lied if you would have told me I
would have been married to him with the
baby two years later
I would have ran for the Hills
you still my way for the straw
Chen's just a mess when she tries to
help out in the restaurant there you go
sweetie thank you so much she doesn't
know what she's doing
[Music]
the she is Huggies trophy wife
I'm not as stupid as everyone thinks and
they can't be our moose what is
[Music]
caviar
I'm not book smart I'm Street Smart
when business started to slow down
Jennifer convinced saki that a remodel
might help bring the people back I was
given no budget they don't put price
tags on things I was just told to go
pick out what you like and now I'm
realizing I have expensive tastes
I was planning on spending 350 000 at
the most Jennifer I wound up spending
almost 950 000 and after I remodeled
this place everything just went down
the pasta is overcooked the food isn't
consistently good it's not fresh have a
good night things just kind of went like
this
it is dead it's empty
I'm stressed out man my dream I own a
restaurant is
that the [__] on fire did you
pay the insurance
dude my parents will go days without
talking
it's always a fight you're teaching me
that I put my heart on my sleeve and I
have no energy anymore to fight with you
you know that
my parents are on the verge of divorce
okay the main reason is because of this
restaurant
I feel like things are out of control
and I feel like we need help
[Music]
after receiving an emotional letter from
the owners
Chef Ramsey has decided to meet Jennifer
at her home
hi Jen come on in before heading over to
the restaurant
wow who's that Ah that's me and sucky
sucky and I what a gorgeous picture
thank you how long it was that five
years ready my goodness me right how are
you I'm nervous you're nervous why are
you nervous
um because when I asked you over I
didn't think you'd actually come I can't
believe why Oprah's sitting in my living
room
how did all this start it started
because I was bartending at the
restaurant is that how you first met
that's how we met actually I lied to get
the job how did you manage that he just
asked if I had experience I said yes but
he realized when I poured my first beer
out of the tap that I didn't know what I
was doing because it was foaming
everywhere else so here was the owner
you were obviously shaking his cocktails
yeah
clearly he had a saucepan instantly he
did you have this hospital for him no no
no why he's not someone I would
typically go for or physical appearances
the age difference between both you as
well 16 years people think I'm a trophy
wife or I'm gold digging it was never
like that I mean he wooed me for eight
months we went everywhere we went to
Hawaii and we went to shows we went to
concerts and then I realized
I loved him they say our beauty is in
the eye of the beholder it really is
true and
he's my Beast
I'm fast forward your relationship with
sake now how's that changed it's not
doing good so just help me understand
that it's very strange because we
remodeled we took a risk and the remodel
was you know a million bucks
did you know the budget I didn't have a
budget he told me to go pick out what I
like that's like sending a lady into a
designer shoe store with no price tags
on the shoes
so it wasn't until after I found out
that the bar was forty thousand dollars
wow wow and the little glitter tiles in
the women's bathroom I picked those out
but I didn't know they were 100 bucks
each so we can't all blame him that's
where I beat myself up and I get mad at
myself because we don't own that
building we don't own that property
slacking has a 10-year lease we've got
10 years to Make It or Break It
sounds like the restaurant's under
immense pressure how do you guys talk to
each other now we don't really
that's what's the hardest part like no I
don't get to work with them every day
side by side so I'm trying to find my
place in the restaurant what condition
is here I mean the restaurant just
really stresses him out because he wants
to work more because he's trying to pull
us out of the hole
he is almost like ignoring the most
important thing in his life the family
grateful for the insights let me tell
you
thank you thank you okay I feel like my
marriage is at a Breaking Point
[Music]
wow look at that sign what is that a big
capital s
let's hope that doesn't stand for [__]
[Music]
well oh hello hello how are you I'm
Robin how are you good thank you
yep am I this way how are you good to
see you bud you like a little fat
penguin I know I am God bless you holy
crap you look more like funeral
Undertakers than you do waiters
everybody here they're working more Thai
and and taxider Shores right hand up you
look like a penguin
let's go down to that coffin no you
don't bounce up and down there you go
together together you'll drop the body
together together oh my goodness me
let's go you show me the table please
okay I'll show you here too nice to meet
you nice to meet you thank you gents
I'd love to meet him please thank you
the restaurants like old style can you
come out here please saki does need
someone to push him because saki is
really old school
oh wonderful yeah now I understand that
you went through a major renovation
maybe you can she'll be around let's go
out this way and remodel this place at
the wrong time and before I knew it it
was big price tag it was saying that it
was too late to start
so these are restaurants oh wow bloody
car yes honestly
here as well this is very plush
chandelier yeah this little tiles here
is fifty dollars each fifty dollars each
yeah so you get those stunning tiles and
you put these shitty butterflies on
there yes my wife's favorite favorite
butterflies so she's a designer
no but she likes the good things I'll
let her do whatever she wanted to do it
she blames me for it wow but that's how
the husband and wife is right the
husband takes a plane whatever the wife
does wow wow the major stuff was
probably right here a new fireplace man
look at that marble on the bar that's
plush right it's quite expensive wow so
tell me about the budget sit down
so obviously it was supposed to be like
350 000 nice you go from
350.
600 Grand over it doesn't make sense so
you got it way out of hand
and the identity of the restaurant what
are we let's see if we passed there
seafood pasta
Continental Cuisine with seafood pasta
well the five stars are decision with
them
[Music]
so it's a continental season
Seafood Steakhouse
Seafood Steakhouse pasta continental
restaurant
right let me eat I'm the one that makes
the decision what's close on the menu
Victor is a chef and I'm the boss
again
just relax you are sweating
look at your shirt I know sweetie
why shouldn't be sweating that's
embarrassing or change your shirt
[Music]
hi Gordon how are you okay how are you
I'm okay thank you your first name is my
name is Mary Mary in your mind what's
wrong with Russians um I believe the
food's outdated oh Chef Ramsey's gonna
go ugh
um would you recommend the lamb shank is
very good well from what I hear I
haven't had it myself the baked
petroleum with crab and based shrimp is
very good for the seafood side as well
from what I hear what was that a great
restaurant well they've always had Greek
owners
trying to throw their Greek twist into
it wow I'm right let's start off um I
have a wonderful Greek sampler
um Crab Louie please and let's go for
the filet mignon thank you
you ready honey yes please what's your
other fruits Greek sampler
we used to do everything from scratch
now they're fully sack over here
[Music]
you're gonna see the true
here we go thank you welcome this is the
Greek sampler
that is ghastly cause I got mashed
potatoes in there it is canned salmon
caviar mixed with some mashed potatoes
canned they mix it with the mashed
potatoes so so canned canned canned a
great tragedy
can sound black whereabouts increasingly
from I don't know but I'll find out if
he said that
you're welcome
he said if you served it in the Greek
Islands they throw you overboard and and
sake where are you from in Greece I'm
from uh uh
from uh
yeah okay
and where's this Crab Louie he's coming
here sake is from kalamanta okay so what
this is the this is the Crab Louie wow
[Music]
disgusting Crab Louie wasn't invented in
the city you think anyone serving it
within a 50 mile radius with higher
respect with fresh gravity yes how much
is that on the menu for 17.95
same with fresh or can't
wow okay
thank you
I'm shocked the next dish ready what do
you think of that one
so the grub the crab smells like fish
like it shouldn't if it's fresh it comes
from the face seed denim
fresh Frozen
fresh frozen out of the can
[Music]
hot back here huh it's hot back here
ah filet mignon
wow
look at it looks like a Mudslide
rubbery
oh
that teriyaki sauce is ghastly it's like
cough medicine that's their way of
teriyaki sauce thank you
gee our food's gross
I said your Teriyaki sucks everybody
loves it directions okay but if you if
he says that the food doesn't taste good
you can't have an excuse for it it's not
his shoes it's a fact we need Chef
Ramsay to snap something in my stepdad
to wake up because right now we're at
Rock Bottom don't don't comment about
the food comment about the food I'm
allowed to thank you no advice
I had enough Grizzlies just go inside
it's a little stuff gone wrong don't get
mad at us when we're trying to help you
you just go inside the dining room I'm
going to the bottom of the totem pole
it'll be okay let's go inside go follow
your mom don't get mad at me just follow
your mom
my restaurant just as much as yours
he is freaking out
after being thoroughly disappointed with
less than fresh food at Spin A Yarn
canned cand
Chef Ramsay heads to the kitchen to have
a little chat with the people
responsible I'm Michaela their daughter
okay nice to see you hi are you uh you
working here yeah okay great it's nice I
look forward to catching with you later
um kitchen that way yeah thank you
hey Chef can you um introduce me to the
team please come over here please
[Music]
Chef Victor nice meeting you uh so
you're the head chef yes okay how long
have you been there Chef my eight years
okay first off
I'm shocked
my lunch was horrific
the first thing that arrived was the the
sample platter
why'd you get salmon caviar I'll mix it
with cold mashed potatoes and serve it
we have from from here that's the old
recipe yeah
yeah okay move on Crab Louie salad why
are you serving canned crab
the fresh crab is hard to get the first
round
oh come on we're in San Francisco we're
in the bay
this filet mignon the sauce was ghastly
it was just it was worse than cough
medicine like you say yes follow the
recipe was here already oh come on
you're the chef hey what do you want me
to do why don't you stand up for
yourself he can answer you
[Music]
are you holding me back
I don't think so
is he holding you back
yes what how did I hold you back I mean
I don't do much things about
cooking sucky I no one's pushing for
standards you're just going through the
motions like a Dead Man Walking
where's the passion
say something man
[Music]
tonight I want to see how this place
functions okay
you guys uh yeah set up I'll see you
shortly yes
down
[Music]
while the lunch was horrific the meeting
was Chef Victor and sake was even
scarier and so Chef Ramsay is hoping to
get more clarity on the workings of the
restaurant tonight at dinner service
[Music]
yes okay but just minutes before the
doors open Gordon squeezed in a meeting
with Jennifer's daughter to get a better
Insight on the fragile situation here at
spin a yard so
Michaela how old are you I'm 14 years
old how many nights a week do you work
in the restaurant I try to help as much
as I can if I need to be here I'll be
here
are you aware of all the sort of
arguments when they're here and they
have fights I try to say hey guys let's
do this somewhere else well you
intervene in terms of being a referee
well sometimes I have to act like the
adult crazy they will go five or four
days without talking and it scares me
that my parents are on the verge of
divorce and you're caught in the middle
of like
almost like in a nightmare that you
really just can't get out of
we're at rock bottom right now
and it's just
a scary situation
okay I'm here to help so what I'm going
to watch and be in the kitchen you need
me come and get me okay okay okay thank
you thank you okay we're not really a
family anymore so I pray and hope that
Chef Ramsay can bring my family back
together
how are you today you guys can come
right this way please have a good meal
you guys
Straw please
so who expedites nobody expedites I keep
an eye on the stations different than
the guys are running back and forth what
does Victor do Victor is stationing back
Victor's washing dishes yeah
he's your head chef you have no sous
chef
what can I say yeah I don't have no help
with this your hands so we can do so
much sucky you know we need to spend the
money oh
while the head chef washes dishes and
the owner watches from the sidelines
entrees are making their way out to
Hungry diners
thank you thank you but they're not
exactly receiving a warm welcome from
the customers I cook better than this
yeah would you like me to take it back
and get you another cut yeah okay sure
definitely
so he wanted medium rare but this is too
red for him
it's like really crazy
what's wrong with Kayla
um what's wrong this ladies in this bag
because the oil is like a soup she's
wrong only and pass this overcooked it's
chaos right now and the blame isn't even
all on the chefs no no
it's on my stepfather too because he's
not doing the job that he needs to be
doing oh no what's wrong with that this
one's cold oh for [__] sake come on
honestly guys how much food is coming
back doesn't it bother you a little bit
I don't know what to say that I'm so
tired
meanwhile the head Chester's washing
dishes
how I got myself into this or how we
ended up here but
okay
[Music]
Jen does anyone care around here
prime rib coming back cold in the middle
wife anemic's fat I thought we were
known for our prime rib
S
I don't need anything I'm just trying to
figure out what the [__] going on I'm
just going inside the diner before you
get pissed off there are lack of
communication it's the death of us
[Music]
what's that smell
I smell it so you smell them well
yesterday but they're not even holes
what's there in the cooler in the cooler
yeah
[Music]
Okay now what's in here
raw meat cooked meat oh dear when were
they cooked
oh gosh what's that chicken or turkey
whatever it is it's pink and lethal
cooked raw chicken
no date
and that's next to a [__] bowl of
strawberries with molding there
oh scummy Fox
you you and you come with me
stay there
look look at this explain that I don't
know I can't I am humiliated
why didn't you check this dude
I mean honestly
hold on it gets worse
hold on you cleaned the refrigerator
what in the [__] is that
[Music]
it's like the padding for my bra oh
that's a chicken
it's pink just just smell that for me
just smell it please God for the love of
God can you open your eyes
hold on that's the cooked meat look at
this here's the raw meat
but it gets worse than that just have a
look
I'm gonna throw up
Jill blood here yeah all in there huh
they're still standing there
they're still sad huh just all sat in
there Jen Jen
look at that I mean honestly
Jennifer
oh [__]
after discovering that spinny Yarns
walking has spun out of control blood
here
Gordon's inspection has Jennifer On The
Run Jen Jen
ah [__]
where's Jen gone I'm right here you're
responsible for 50 of this we're talking
about losing money staring at it
you have to take responsibility
well the guys treat the food but you've
got to be checking then osaki come on I
hope you have a plan because I don't
know where to start right now I've got a
plan get the [__] out of here
unbelievable you can point the blame but
there's no excuse for what happened
tonight in the end for me it falls back
on sake he's the boss his name is on
everything Jennifer I bring the produce
I expect them to take care of it okay
well you knew Chef was coming to our
[__] refrigerator
[Music]
stop
stop we're gonna want to [__] come
back here
guys have a word with you both please
yes sir
disgusting I've been waiting to say I
mean just I mean I didn't expect to be
this bad oh guys I don't know what to
say saki I'm I
if I'd seen that before series I
wouldn't let you cook anything tonight
where do I start when everyone's given
up I'm not giving up stuff I have a lot
to lose over here
Jen if you're going to be involved then
get involved if there's going to be a
successful business with a successful
marriage you've got to be United I tried
try harder
[Music]
I will I'll be a [__] if I have to get
back in there and get that place clean
make them respect what you bought
[Music]
[__] let's get it out right now let's
do it nobody goes home
unbelievable
unless we use the last side of the
cheats I need to start refreshing to
spending more time inside the kitchen
whatever happened happened now we gotta
started the right way Victor no excuses
anymore let's get this thing going let's
start fresh all right you can actually
blame Victor I can blame anybody
but the bad night is me
for me
it's clear to Gordon that Spin A Yarn is
destroying a marriage Chad how are you
hi where's saki but ironically this
restaurant cannot be saved unless the
couple is United
yeah kitchen nice and clean we'll do our
best I'm ready I find it hard to gauge
your best because I haven't seen it so
far
there are some big issues here clearly
not just in the kitchen but I think
there's issues between both of you
there's no communication between YouTube
I'm gonna call as I see it
I just feel like I've had it though
because he's not gonna change I have no
Authority and you don't let me make a
decision it's just
It's Just Dance
Manning up and understanding that you're
destroying not just yourself but your
family at the same time you're gonna
have to change buddy you're gonna have
to change
rapidly
I will have nothing more than to have my
wife next to me over here and it works
together so why doesn't it happen
because it's not ignorance is it
no I think I need the chains
it's not good to have things in life
nobody around with you to share with I'm
going to tell myself
I want to change me okay
yeah all my support
[Music]
okay
yes I love you okay I love you too
[Music]
now that Saki and Jennifer have
committed to being a team
Jeff Ramsey has made some changes for
tonight's dinner service okay first of
all tonight this business is going to be
run by the owners how weird is that
you sacking I'm gonna fall back in love
with your kitchen tonight because you're
Expediting okay and tonight we're going
to do the most amazing prime rib and we
will carve tableside tonight this card
is gonna be handled by
together
[Music]
that's right
you
this is your restaurant
[Music]
I'm gonna puke what if I puke on the
table you will not be picking on the
tables forget that think of your
business
but you've been ignoring this business
when you want to be involved
there's only one way to get involved and
that's jumping at the deep end okay I've
got every confidence that you can do it
I'm feeling very nervous right now
I don't even know how to cut prime rib I
can't do this look at this
that is
look hold the knife no no no legit I
watch too much CSI I can't do this
oh
come on
thank you ah oh my God
okay
oh my God please let me do this and
please don't let me gag
for tonight's dinner service hello how
are you guys doing today Chef Ramsay has
added a tableside prime rib new specials
this evening we got tableside prime rib
he wants to not only create excitement
in what has been a morbid dining room
but he hopes to take some of the
pressure off the kitchen okay come on
guys let's go however this plan relies
on Jennifer overcoming her fears okay
Jen big deep breath let's go you're
right you look a bit nervous do you want
to swap place in McKenna and I'll get
her to spice it
[Music]
all right
I love you all right
oh my gosh
freaking out because she can't handle
serving fatty meat she's gonna have to
deal with it two minutes what am I doing
Prime rib's getting cold let's go let's
go Jen as I say in Vegas It's Showtime
this is going to be an interesting night
who's having the prime rib tonight you
guys okay
[Music]
you can't
I'm sorry no come on Jen I've never cut
meat before a chef stop that forget that
now that's gone okay we start again we
still haven't met our best nothing but
our best he thinks I was being stupid
but I really didn't know how to cut the
meat or how to handle it or what the
rules were the lights are on but there's
no one at [__] home oh
all right
[Music]
there you go we get the door every table
own it and smile again oh my God I used
to like him I don't anymore
how is everything so far tonight guys
good all right
oh Jesus Christ almighty
nicely not like you're about to stab
sucky there you go come on
I just want to hide that's Jennifer
where you going
God Bless America
[Music]
we did a cartwheel
smile
Jen turn around
don't walk backwards into a door
Jen what you served out there I can't
let you do that
no don't get all [__] into with me my
name's Gordon not [__] suck it I'm
not yelling at you okay okay they
deserve the best if you can't give them
the best then don't do it we're getting
worked up over nothing that's how you
work and it's how you learn if you don't
want to learn there's no point you're
doing this
stuffy how long on that prime rib five
more minutes thank you I'm not gonna
fail I'm not gonna cry brilliant here we
go I am definitely on board I want to do
whatever it takes I took a one second
time out I sucked it up got my head back
in the game went back out there you guys
ready I think so would you like the
horseradish on the side or on the meat
do you have a preference on the side
it's just fine on the side you got it
okay so there you go enjoy good well
done good job thank you I learned a lot
tonight I learned how to cut meat
you did good thank you all right all
right
[Music]
now that Saki and Jennifer have proved
they are committed to this restaurant
come through please Chef Ramsay has
given them a new and more focused
identity on Steakhouse
hustle along please thank you
[Music]
okay
when I first arrived just under 200
dishes insane this menu is in accordance
to what you've got to work with easy
effective and glamorous and plain to
your strengths let's start off down the
end you've got a delicious sweet corn
chowder next to that the Carpaccio say
with onions parmesan arugula and an age
balsamic vinegar that's tight come to
the focal point of the most amazing
Steakhouse start off with a grilled New
York strip next to that you've got the
filet mignon stunning okay delicious
lamb chops we'll cook them on the rack
we won't open them up a delicious prime
rib which was a big hit last night the
seafood a wonderful pan seared salmon
halibut and scallops I love it and this
menu is big enough for you to hit
Perfection it'll be great now we can
finally lift off of rock bottom and it's
all because of Chef Jen how are you
feeling I'm so happy excellent now dig
in have a taste yeah this is good guys
oh my God try that
people are gonna die to come back to eat
this food I think my customers are gonna
Rave about it to everybody have you seen
the new menu as Vineyard it's good
but you're not way too often to dinner
and see the reactions of the people that
will be walking in obviously I think
they're going to be shocked
[Music]
it's only minutes before relaunch night
and Chef Ramsay has an important
announcement to make and listen I've
just been told you've got half of the
San Jose Sharks in for dinner time
awesome oh my God that's fine they're
coming when you see big names like that
in their local restaurant it spreads
rapidly that's the place to be in look
after them yeah have fun and sell yes we
got to push the specials especially the
pride me if I want my wife to work
tonight make sure she cuts a lot of
privacy let's go
[Music]
thank you
it's relaunch night it's been a yarn hi
guys hi guys funny yarn and with the
restaurant packed I think I'm going to
have the prime rib a lot of the Prime
ribs
the customers are finding one particular
menu item irresistible
[Music]
we've been together so long and I hey
see saki like these days where you
motivated
girl right there behind the line but
let's move it was sake Expediting and
supporting his head chef the first
appetizers are making their way out to
the dining room here we go enjoy it guys
and the dishes are a hit are you gonna
share that hahaha
oh here she is stand by here's the dolly
with the trolley okay cats arriving look
at that prime rib everybody to die for
who's having the prime rib
medium okay excellent hold on time that
night when we slice off
[Music]
enjoy okay
the size of a door a little bit thinner
next time we're here to make money not
lose it
I'm going to give you a great piece of
the meat wow so there's your lucky day
primer before
Jen you don't have to give away half the
[__] prime rib
with Jennifer continuing to carve big
portions
and the San Jose Sharks arriving the
prime rib is running dangerously low did
you see the sharks
the sharks are swimming closer let's go
hello sharks I'm doing good it took me a
long time to come over and build up the
courage come over here and ask you
please don't order the prime rib
s but I'm totally joking
I need that to get in here it's a big
one yeah
[Music]
oh for [__] sake you are kidding me I
messed up
okay that's so it's a big ticket
if you run out now I'm gonna flip my lid
it's relaunch night it's been a yarn and
with Jennifer carving massive portions
the kitchen is running out of prime rib
family is left only this
kitchen is at a complete standstill if
you run out now I'm gonna flip my lid
Victor yes you have enough for 12 right
ah oh my god oh
come on
I got one more
he had one of his League Victor well
done I cook another one on my own so
yeah
an emergency
Las Americas beautiful look at that okay
let's go here we go sharks now yes work
in Harmony are you coming behind me with
12. I've got it right behind you with
head chef Victor coming through to save
the day Jennifer and sake now work as a
team to serve the San Jose Sharks
that was hard you did a great job
Jennifer had a lot of confidence gave up
that's for sure even though we had all
these photos of prime minister got a
little nervous but yeah not to be good
how's your meal guys
I hope you enjoyed it huh yeah probably
was big enough
wonderful thank you guys you're the best
sweet that's nice
that's my man I'm really proud of sake
to have a successful restaurant feels
surreal it's so great to have the
support of the community and it feels
good to be back on top real nice having
you guys we like have a great season up
it's been a crazy week let me tell you
the difference from the start of the
week to the end of the week to be night
and day the most important thing is the
three youth like that one little units
all actively involved in the business
Hands-On
Jen it felt tonight that you were
handling that trolley for the last five
years thank you I feel like I finally
have a role in this restaurant and I
never thought it would be the queen of
goodie
well done thank you for you honestly
you've got one bright future let me tell
you thank you exactly yes sir to see
falling back in love with your business
is exemplary you must not stop you may
have sprouts for our place
it's a pleasure giving me new confidence
to keep going again I was kind of burned
out with financially and everything but
now I think the future looks good
wow I am so grateful for Chef Ramsay he
saved our lives he changed our lives and
you keep pushing
and stop being so nervous with it okay
I'm just so grateful for the opportunity
to turn things around and start a new
future for my family good job
great job good night sweet thank you
Chef thank you and he's off like a ship
in the night
[Music]
it's been a yarn for you tonight Jen
proved that she's not a trophy wife
and she has gone from a spectator to a
force with a trolley but tonight she's
not the only one because it's all about
a team effort and that's exactly what
this person needs to succeed teamwork
wow 80 grand on a bathroom
holy crap
[Music]
in the weeks that followed the new menu
featuring The Amazing prime rib okay who
are the lucky recipients
attract new customers from the Bay Area
we're falling behind okay
[Music]
while Jennifer and saki's relationship
still has its quirks
[Music]
they're both actually enjoying working
together to make spinner yarn the place
to be once again I love working with
sake and communicating and it feels good
to do things right it feels great
foreign